welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz
today I am in Bristol I'm joined by Tom
white who is the founder and owner of a
business called paratus people and their
recruiting agency based out of Bristol
but also have offices in the Netherlands
Brussels Amsterdam sorry yes I'm Sonoma
now Brussels Munich and you guys are a
recruitment agency that specialized in
the IOT sector correct I did Google that
out before I came up today okay what and
that's Internet Internet of Things
Internet or thing yeah it's interesting
name that engineer yeah left me curious
so it's essentially anything that's
connected to the Internet
any divider that's connected to the
Internet yeah sounds like a good niche
to be in in today's world talk well it's
growing well it'd been looking forward
to this mate and rightwise so obviously
I've got a couple of questions for you
that I definitely know are she okay with
you obviously having your own
recruitment business definitely gonna
have a focus on your journey with your
own business so you've obviously been
building and running your own
recruitment business now for is it
comments or four years yeah so so we
incorporated April 2016
I'm probably kind of soft launched and
then really got going at the start of
2017 core so we're always like to start
how did Tom White enter the lovely word
recruitment
let's not them well do you know what
probably the same as everyone else wrote
it so I kind of fell into it yeah so I
was actually selling phones believe it
or not really yeah but kind of how
difficult is that which I wasn't doing
it face to face
I was within business sales so over the
telephone oh okay that's all I sell into
businesses God's honest truth is I
relocated to Blackpool of all places
don't ask me why and ended up selling
corporate phone packages for a company
called focusing connections okay
and he had the tree for the Myo is I
kind of blacked myself the job right I
said I'd word orange I'd never worked
orange I said I worked in phone sales
never worked in phone sales and kind of
just took to it really well yeah so you
know I remember going in on the first
day did really well sold sold
I think you know about 15 20 phones and
packages to different companies
yeah body end of the first week warm
leads May 22 a warm piping hot that's
you know what it wasn't even warm right
so we started we had it used to be a
banding system cool used to be called
IVR so you used to know what users would
would be spending on their phone
contracts and who to pick up more
companies that kind of target and yeah
by the end of the first week one what
was then a virgin red letter day or than
if you remember those so they're kind of
like corporate prizes they used to hold
in red-letter days and yeah it did
really really well that was a Comley job
I was earning about thousand pound a
week you know just selling phones and in
case you're a long way in blackboard can
assure you of that
so sales mm-hmm and how the recruitment
come about then so so I'm from Bristol
okay and a rep Tareq basically contacted
me I didn't know what a rectorate was at
the time I still think a lot of people
probably don't know what race is the
most common story yeah and yeah so this
this chat contacted me and was telling
me a story about someone I later met in
in real life chuckle Charlie Walker who
owns a company called harmonic about how
he was earning big-time billa yeah yeah
about he was about he was earning like
125 pounds a year doing recruitment and
why did he tell you about him did you
know him or did he said you know I think
it was good it was Bristol and I never
knew the guy I never knew what
recruitment was I just knew that
recruitment consultants are ringing me
about jobs that I couldn't do
so I just climb a fort like this is okay
this is a joke industry right and anyhow
a guy set about before an interview a
company called Ashland consult in back
in February 2008 yeah and yeah I had one
if you've got the job and that was their
[ __ ] that he'd been in though you've
been in recruitment since then
yeah February 2008 how did it how did
they so you recruitment him was it in
line with Tom you can earn some yeah
that's that a grand a week and Blackpool
mate yeah way away bomb Kate's way way
way more than that over here like how do
they sell it you have interest always
curious so yeah so essentially they were
basically saying that you could earn you
know a six-figure salary which we all
know to be the case now in recruitment
right but I think the problem with
wrecked wrecks or in my view at that
time is that it's so far detached from a
23 24 year old saying that you're gonna
earn 100,000 pounds a year is really pie
in the sky right if you'd have said that
you're gonna earn forty fifty thousand
pounds a year it's probably going to be
more achievable it seems so distant that
you actually don't believe what they're
saying yeah yeah yeah you know and I'm
I'm probably quite a skeptical person
right my friends would say that but I
reckon it served me well so just to set
the scene then so entered recruitment
into too far in 2008 yeah and then how
long did you work in that agency for so
I think off the top of my head I left
about August 2009 okay so little stint
there yeah and then you joined another
business yes
so joined a company called people source
and October 2009 I'd say before for
think really okay and then how long were
you there for nearly six years or
resigned in month December 2015
so seven years working for somebody else
hmm those billion days so just quickly I
said now run your own business he's
still very much on the tours you still I
was at the start I think any yeah this
start yeah so I think you know
traditionally speaking you know a lot of
recruitment companies are set up because
you get a good bit up right
for whatever reason either born out of
frustration or over one of doing
something their own we're chasing a
dream they start a company so good
bidders tend to set up companies and
then very much hands on until such a
time that they can build a team around
them was yoga Billa yeah I was alright I
think it was just short of a million
really yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] that's
a big big number yeah and so and use a
contractor career predominately contract
yeah have you always been in nice you
said IRT is
liest like Ward markup again so at the
time I was doing broadcast technology so
a lot of work around set-top boxes and
television deployment at television and
is that core seven in Sweden yeah very
much so I mean one of the reasons why
paratus works in the IT space is that
there was a lot of good people in
broadcast who were fate in a period of
consolidation in the market right you
know these days people watch Netflix and
a lot of the TV vendors that you know
they're main you know goal is to have
Netflix displayed on a device yeah
whereas when I started in the industry
it was about a traditional set-top box
it that sound on top of a TV and there
was there was a lot of work that went
into that yeah so this is the basic year
so a lot basically a lot of good
engineers have transcended into into the
IOT market okay yeah so before we go
into the journey of you have your own
business
let's just talk so as I was sharing
review over lunch like definitely a lot
of builders that listen to this right
yeah aspiring business owners and
business owners so that's your point of
when you got into equipment you had
someone telling you that you could earn
yeah a lot of money I feel like a lot of
people definitely feel the same when you
were when you were saying look my best
year was probably just under a million
and I'm assuming that you built up to
that and to follow fit around that so
that's definitely feel a million miles
away you know a lot of people right what
what what what are some of the things
you think contribute contributed to do
you get into that level because that is
high-performing yeah I think thank you I
think at the time it was who are year
was that you know
I think I think between the Wow I mean I
was I was earning yeah between 300,000
and a half a million a year gross yeah
between 2012 to 2015 I Wow
so did very well and I think kind of
what contributed to that was the fact
that in a nutshell I liked nice [ __ ] and
no one was gonna buy it for me okay
she's very motivated yeah not motivated
driven driven so motivation comes and
goes yeah driven it would take you
through the hard day's right you know
and I always say this at interview to
people right you know if it's snowing
outside you're gonna call in sick you're
gonna come in do you want to watch
Netflix or do you actually want to come
in and make money and do stuff yeah and
for me it was I was I was driven right I
really like nice cars and there was
frankly frustrated that you know not
being born into a lot of wealth for me
my family you know a very middle-class
right but I wasn't I wasn't born into
modes of money that in order to generate
that I had to get off my ass and go and
do it myself
whether so okay how how did you
cultivate that drive would you say I had
an opportunity when I when I joined the
business to essentially do what I wanted
to do and craft the market and one of
the the benefits about the company at
the time was I was able to come in and
and focus on what I had been doing yeah
but I have carte blanche to to grow that
how I wanted to do it yeah and I could
see a lot of opportunity I could see a
lot of competitors in the space that
were working in that market but perhaps
not doing as well as they could do okay
or stretching it as far as it could go
yeah so that's there's a big opportunity
yeah a massive opportunity yeah going
back to your question about being
skeptical skeptical about the earnings I
think yeah you are skeptical about the
earnings and I think you know you have
to have a lot of Drive and you have to
really really want it because the job is
hard and I and often say to people if
you can make it in recruitment
you can pretty much make it in anything
yeah because it you have to it calls
upon so many different techniques skills
and attributes that you can't
necessarily learn you know from an
academic perspective right okay so just
quickly then so we'll see you you now
employ people I'm sure now you obviously
you've you've been there and done it
right been a very high performing biller
yeah so what what are some of their you
go through that process and I doubt
hiring for your team previously as well
what what do you think of some of the
common things that prevent people from
getting to those sorts of levels that
you got to would you say yeah okay so I
think and I can't speak for everyone so
I can go on the experience that I've had
from interviewing people I think the
idea of earning good money and billing
good money and the trappings that come
with that is very enticing but a stark
reality of how to get to it can be
sometimes too much for people in the
sense that you know recruitment as it as
it was and staffing or talent solutions
however we want to call it to these days
because you know without meaning to get
sidetracked I think recruitments dead
but that's another topic it takes a lot
of energy it takes a lot of effort it
takes a lot of Drive and and I think
sometimes people aren't really aware of
just how much it may take over in the
same way like a method actor would
rehearse for their role and live and
breathe that character for a period of
time you have to engulf yourself within
a market to really understand it and to
separate yourself against other people
that may be in that market and I think
if you're willing to do that and truly
take take that on board then you will be
successful
so it's sacrifices you are talking about
you could call it sacrifices I would
call it more priorities yeah yeah I'll
get that but what you saying is on the
face of it looks great sounds great yeah
Tom I'm up for air but in those sorts of
numbers yeah but when when push comes to
shove yeah are you willing to put in the
work
yeah essentially and that that's what
you think is the I think the keeping I
think you know there's a there's a
there's a quote by Warren Buffett right
that says that an idiot where the plan
will always be a genius without a plan
hmm
and you know never is that more true in
in recruitment or staffing or whatever
you want to call it right because
ultimately you you have to put in the
effort you have to do the basics right
and and this pray this phrase has used a
lot in in in in our circles right and
whenever you hit hard times or whenever
you want to progress you have to do the
basics right you have to do the hard
stuff first yeah and it's easier to cut
the corners mm-hm
and one of the reasons why you know I
think the work that you're doing is
great is that you you acknowledge the
fact that you've got to have a digital
presence you've got to be aware of self
branding and promotion of yourself as an
individual to use combined with
traditional phone sells and the ability
to hold and articulate a good
conversation with someone that maybe you
know people that you wouldn't would not
necessarily socialize with Ryan but from
a business context and and to to extract
information to go through requirements
analysis and to find out useful you know
Intel that you can use to your advantage
and I think those two things together is
really powerful
in its day and age okay find all like
just real practical question on that
because people always ask me about it
what what did a typical Tom Wyatt day
look like in those days how did you
structure there I think yeah so I think
it depends if you ask my old boss right
so at the start I'd worked really hard
I'm not I'm not gonna lie right that
really really would him in work one well
so I used to say to my old boss in that
if you ever listen to this he'll
probably hear it but I used to I used to
say like I cannot understand how people
get in at 8:30 9 o'clock when this this
this environment this company will allow
you to write your own paycheck
I could not fathom the fact that people
wouldn't get in early and prioritize not
sacrifice other things in in their world
if you get a satellite seven o'clock
7:15 used to literally run to work I
used I moved closer to work on purpose
to get close like to be closer to the
environment you split the money room
yeah but it is the money room you know
we're here to earn money we're here to
you know to change up to change our
lives to do something to make up and to
make a difference right you going early
yeah the rest of that don't so so the
first two hours of my day was absolutely
manic it was it was frantic right so you
used to come in have most things
automate is a set up so that I would
have either leads in my inbox candidates
ready to go yeah everything so I could
push product out the door okay
so I attend CVS never send intros I was
saying business development emails
messages to people from 7:30 to 9:30 and
then followed that up for our day
yeah so the first two hours are just
absolutely the stuff that's imminent
yeah should drive revenue quite quickly
yeah Severson on fact than what so
you're doing all that before some people
we even written the office yeah like you
know people used to turn up right you
know even bacon sandwiches at like nine
o'clock and they used to look and be
like you know you know you're not gonna
get anywhere right you know what's
what's the point but I cannot but the
finger is like I'm slightly older now
right I'm mid-thirties it's my 35th
birthday next month and I think back
then I was a probably a little bit more
bullish and perhaps slightly more
outspoken than I am now if you can
believe it and I guess it's I guess for
certain people you know they want to be
an environment where they want to do
where they want to earn 40 50 60 K
because you know they want a nice
holidays nice height cetera but their
content were of that whereas for me I
wasn't content because enough isn't and
yes you really want to do yeah and I
kind of think it's like a tap right you
know it's either on and it's full
flowing or it's off to be a Midway
recruiter
it's actually quite difficult you know
because it means that you actively have
to stop at some point you do a couple of
deals and he sit there and you know go
on BBC Sport and and relax address so
that was who wasn't yeah no not at all
yeah after 9:30 so after 9:30
sorry it's a kept going off after so
often I thought it will be following up
on everything that I did yeah being
super proactive yeah
calling people had many many clients or
was it just quite varied so yeah so to
be honest with you when I when I was bit
him well you know I used to just
literally bring switchboards and try and
get business off the back of
switchboards they did it with Tesco I
did it with legal in general and they've
got some big accounts yeah of word not
knowing any names and just being able to
manipulate the people on the phone on
the switchboard using like social
engineering techniques to go to go
through and and get terms and I used to
get terms signed off the back of one
calls what hitting the switch yeah
hitting the switch and honestly do your
research
this isn't the truth right and for me it
was a test it was it was a it was it was
a battle to see if you could do that
right and and if you could actually be
skilled and adept enough you know in in
in in your language and and your
research to be quickly enough to do it
so I remember with legal in general I
mean it wasn't even a niche that I was
focusing on at the time and for some
reason I just chased down a lead and
they had mentioned something about
solvency 2 which was an insurance reform
that I'm sure yeah no insurance yeah
yeah and I just muted the mic and
googled it and you know and and and
managed and managed to manage to kind of
get terms on but it wasn't you know I
want to add to the point what wasn't
just a black right you know I'd back
this up I'd actually research I've
actually studied it
I've actually go really really deep into
the subject matter and and eventually
that's when I sort of found obviously
the work that I've been doing and what I
set the company up by going you know an
inch wide and a mile deep into the
subject hmm so then did Tom White take a
lunch
yeah yeah I always had lunch but I never
I never went for lunch does that make
sense or is that a patent on no and well
maybe at the time cuz I was on comm only
for a long time really so yeah I didn't
have anything in the afternoon you did a
similar thing that's been really
proactive at the start like you know
probably some of my guys in the office
I'm probably gonna listen to this right
but I've got I've got to be honest and
I've got to tell the truth at one point
when you know I was billing a lot of
money and I was placing a lot of
contractors you know eight to 14 a month
some at some mumps which in tech is a
lot right we're not talking about temps
we're talking about you know quite high
margin contractors I'd sit back and I'd
relax a little bit because really yeah
because I was on comm only and I was
earning you know more money than I knew
what to do with it but I think yeah at
the time looking back now if you know if
I if I was a little bit smarter or or
were to do things in a slightly
different way I would have focused much
quicker in a niche I would have doubled
down in that niche I would have saved a
lot more money than buying supercars and
ridiculous shoes and I think that's such
an interest I'm glad you said that
yeah who like who speaks to people about
they're giving people ideas on how to be
smart with their money yeah it's a good
point so I think I think it's the
structure so just to talk a little bit
about paratus right so we we have an
independent financial adviser a nice who
will you did a post yeah yeah so we're
talking we're talk to people about where
what to do with their money had to be
smart with the money make the money work
for them I'm fully I fully appreciate
the fact that yeah you know recruitment
whilst it's a career you know you want
to get the best out of it and you want
to get the most out of it and you know
it may be a stepping stone into
something else and that that's
absolutely fine so we would advise
people on property purchases we actually
have a consultant loan scheme as well
yeah so you probably had that - yeah I
think at the time I think there were
pros and cons I mean I never had any
training as such
I never really had any guidance in the
market that I was doing and it was a bit
of a free-for-all so you could argue
that that was quite poor and that these
days it would be very difficult for
people to bill well and quickly and come
at your speed but the flip side to that
is it's survival of the fittest right
and you know you need to make money
certainly on a commission only element
as well because if you don't you know
you're not billing you're not you're not
owning anything
see it seems like like you just
relentless basically just put in the
work like what you wanted it yeah I
wanted it I had a lot of Drive but I
think quite smart about it as well so
you know did certain things did did work
around branding perhaps you know even
when I knew it was branding like cute
about how to represent myself to the
wider market but you know also I had
quite a passion about what I did so you
know at university I actually studied
towards two degrees but one of them was
in computing and that really helped
because a lot of my friends were getting
into the industry that I was recruiting
for so I had a bit of an interest I had
a bit of an a passion about that and I
think that really does help yeah but
yeah relentless and I realized I was
good at something
yeah and I really really wanted to be
the best lover down yeah exactly triple
down on that always want to start your
own business yeah that's you know what
that's an interesting question yes and
no you might all see you always hear all
the time like some let's billion quite
well the mindset is arm
the light wasn't yeah for myself guys
are my own pocket so he was on
commission only yeah so what so I was
doing well I was earning well at the
time you know prior to my departure from
the company we were we were going
through a we're going through an event
right yeah we exit didn't yeah and we
were quiet by large corporate and I
think to me at the time I thought the
things are going to probably change
significantly and that that feel and
that effect
that you could have with the MD and a
good relationship might be slightly
separated but I also I also really
wanted to focus on doing something for
myself and Chapin chasing a dream as
such right and I think that that's
really important that you you go for
something because it's um get an inch
right and you're the only way to cure
that itches to actually go and do it
mm-hm and I didn't want to leader what
if kind of like you know and it when you
earning like a lot of cash it kind of
earning a bit more doesn't really yeah
it doesn't yeah it doesn't really matter
an effect actually on a PA ye basis at
bat then you know you're paying you know
super high rate tax so the deal value
and what you actually see is is really
marginal and it comes a point where you
actually probably couldn't bill anymore
I think when I got to like sixty out I
was like well is it I'm not actually
that incentivize didn't make much of a
difference once you get to the yeah did
you have a business plan yes so good I'm
quite a mercurial character does that
mean so so my interpretation is that I
I'm quite I think I think about a lot of
plans I think about a lot of things
there's a lot of things going on in my
head at one time sometimes quite
abstract and I can go I can go for full
forward with something a hundred percent
and then sometimes I might just want to
kind of kick back and reflect on the
situation so yeah it's quite hard to
predict right I had a business plan in
the sense in in my head about what I
wanted to do yeah I had to present it to
a bank of course so I needed to actually
put on paper maybe add all this cash
mate yeah yeah of course I had that but
the thing is yeah no I didn't get a loan
but I got an invoice discounting
facility okay so it's always always that
way that cuz it's contract they pay yeah
okay that cash flow that's cash flow
yeah so it's called a CI D facility a
lot of people start with like an if'
facility where invoice factoring where
does that lot some of they yeah so I
spoke just on abate as most people do
but I mean it was quite expensive okay
yeah I wasn't a monkey on that but no no
no your
like it's cool and anyway the cost of
boring is cheap and has been cheap for
locking for a long time sort of so the
smart man wouldn't use his own money
right he'd borrow a cheaper rate and and
use it and make it and make it work for
itself at a higher rate so I'd probably
even if I could cellphone contractors I
probably still borrow money from the
bank yeah business to do that yeah I
kind of knew what I wanted to do it is
more about and it was a nice kind of
cathartic exercise and crystallizing my
faults right yeah okay it's a first year
then yeah how's that interesting so you
went from obviously bidam yeah well yeah
interesting what happened what would
what did you bill in the first year was
it just you for the whole yeah yeah
so remember what you build in the first
year so it's less about Billings and
more around turnover and then working
out NFI okay so edify first year well so
we did just coming up to about two
million in the first year yeah just over
the first year net income no no no no
okay
and if I were probably taking about 26%
27% from that okay that was just me yeah
really yeah that's [ __ ] break that
down then son how like what how to drive
again right and was you doing this just
at home or no no I got an office okay
so people could get advice and people
can get a lot of advice from a lot of
different people yeah poke about this oh
yeah right but but ultimately you know
so I remember I speaking to my dad about
this and what Dad was said you know you
could just you've got a you know got a
really nice house in Clifton it's a nice
part Bristol and you could just sit
upstairs and and and bill will make
money in a spare bedroom and I said yeah
but for me like I want an office I want
to be in an office yeah I want to do
this upstairs because hey I have too
many distractions cetera so I'm yeah I
rented a small office in Queen Square
and Bristol sat there on my own
celebrated success or my how was that
because yeah it was it was interesting
it was different but starting from
scratch there's a brill
it's a real good feeling right to be
able to create something from scratch
again and and and I think a lot of it
and there was a couple of naysayers as
well you know to be honest maybe that my
form of business or other people to say
you know it's very difficult to build
your book back up when you talk about
contractors right and Pete and that's
why people sometimes stay and why
companies offer retainers to get them
outta business because it's difficult to
redo it I just thought well if I could
if I can get to sixty out on my own then
I do it again and I know remember one
month you know places like seven
contractors in a month
two of them were hosted by just ringing
up a a massive Japanese system
integrator that people would probably
guess and did a really good job with
them on the phone and took a couple of
contractors on payroll them at like
eighteen percent margin that helped me
do a couple of deals and yeah just quick
right just just quick but which it was
so what was the so how did you start
building this something was you just
straight again doing we're doing best
matter smashing the switchboards
no so you didn't need I didn't need this
master switch towards M because
obviously I knew people who leverage
your network yeah I leveraged the
network but I'd like to say for the
record I uphold all my covenants you
know I was under a restrictive covenant
not even work in recruitment for six
months because I was part of an urn that
I was on in here might as well what did
you do for six months I've got bored
frankly okay yeah I was kind of thinking
about other things that I could do other
businesses other ideas you know like I'd
set up a fashion business back in 2014
as a bit of a side hustle yeah could I
could see all these like pop-up brands
that were like you know making loads of
money and like in jeans and you know
guys our own super tight jeans at the
base in jeggings and they're thinking
like you can make money out of this but
and then I kind of I kind of thought
what I want to I want to focus on what
I'm good at I'm gonna focus on I'm
building something to myself so for six
months probably spend a lot of money
went on nice holidays yeah and and
chilled out but was he gonna get back
into it but respected the fact that you
know it was probably a good thing for me
to take a bit of a break
all right what was the biggest challenge
in the first rate figures chancing I
mean the two million first year yeah
these last great right so yeah I mean
the clearly someone that I mean little
you did it for someone else let alone
for yourself he's going the work had the
drive yeah what was the biggest
challenge I think yeah so for me the
biggest challenge in the first year was
understanding fact from fiction with
regards to how to set up a business
infrastructure and specifically in in in
recruitment right and again this comes
back to taking advice knowing what deal
was to do what banks what back-office
yeah and it was set up an office in in
Amsterdam pretty quickly
yeah we've been like ten months I'm
going to start dealing with Dutch
lawyers and you know no trees and you
know dealing with complicated city was
done this yeah I was just fact-finding
right and I guess I guess that you know
when I talk about recruitment I talked
about the fact that ultimately you need
a computer and a phone and and I love
that you know and I love the fact that
sometimes you can just be you know
skilled enough to be able to speak to
people obtain fact from fiction to find
out this information so just making lots
of calls and find out what was right to
do what wasn't right to do so I guess
the infrastructure but I also found that
quite fun right could it was a new
challenge yeah to build infrastructure
and do things right and as I say we went
to CID straightaway rather new invoice
factoring which meant we weren't getting
you know taking the mickey out of on our
on our rates by companies that son of a
and others you know is a competitive
landscape and I think for me the
overarching difficulty not had at the
start of journey was was was internal
recruitment which we yeah and it's
always ironic when you speak to
customers because they kind of they kind
of think that you should be really good
at it but equally we're good at finding
the people that we find in our
marketplace but not necessarily the
people for us yeah so I think yeah we
made some hires made some mistakes well
in the first year you had tried to hire
people you
yeah pretty quickly really yeah and I
think I do always want it to be bigger
than just you then a hundred percent
like yeah I didn't want to be a
lifestyle beast if you do that from day
one yeah absolutely
you know the plan was to grow or the
plan is is to grow have an event and
properly form part of a larger
organization yeah which is why we're so
niche in what we do we don't want to
just be a generous technology company
where there's so many oven it's just
like where's your USP what what are you
doing differently to everyone else
so um the biggest challenge was well it
was a new challenge was building the
infrastructure yeah getting all the
tools and things in place to help you
scale them do one scale yeah and then it
was actually a harem for yourself yeah
all right quick one then - right - just
to wrap up that first year
yeah know what you know now yeah
starting the recruitment business is
mine yeah what tools should I definitely
looking at to invest in so you said cuz
obviously like I don't get don't not
fully understanding contract work so did
you know some of a and other comparison
that yeah so yeah so what I saw was I
should definitely looking at I would
look at investing in okay so I mean it
depends so I'm quite contract heavy yeah
even I've done permanent ultimately
start off real light you don't get sold
to dream that you need super fancy
websites etc yeah you know WordPress is
super stable these days you know cure
you can get a wordpress site up for 500
pounds if you want it to I'd arrange a
good deal with a bank yeah so what's the
dish pros and cons for that just for
people listener for the way that you got
to you the way that you dealt with the
bank over yeah like we just saw no way
because they're a big brand but yeah the
factoring company in there so why I'd
get a good broker okay so there's a
couple of well-known brokers out there
that I know personally they're
incentivized to get you the best deal
possible
they make Commission fear probably about
a couple of thousand if they get you an
agreement yeah and a debenture over the
business in order to do contract
recruitment okay and I would make sure
that you get in the most competitive
deal possible with super competitive
right now yeah or has been for some time
you know there's talk of the cost
potentially rising because of obviously
fluctuations in well not fluctuations
because it breaks it back yes alright
yeah I'd get a good deal with a bank and
I start off small right you you spoke to
Matt
Collinwood I think at one point the line
about headcount is vanity and bottom
line Ursula is so apt because you know
the first question that everyone asks
you how bigger you know yeah but if you
own that says it yeah and it's you know
it's the wrong question the right
question should be like you know what's
the NFI yeah you know how is everyone
billing you know and what people are up
to speed you know not how many people do
our could you could have 20 people but
for them could be billing it could be
like yeah Pareto's law of 80/20 which
normally is the case yeah okay
second year then yeah how's that so
second year was interesting because we
moved from a small kind of form an
office to a 10-man office started
recruiting yeah bought in an ops manager
early really yeah why did you do that
good question asked myself no I'm joking
I bought in an ops manager because I
needed certainly more structure and I
think you have to you have to think
about your strengths and weaknesses so I
was good a bit building you know a
business sells and what-have-you but the
biggest team I ever had at my old
business was like three people right I
never I never ran massive teams and part
partly the reason for that is good I
wanted to do it on my own
yeah but because I didn't have that
experience of learning from lessons that
you know that that's something that
maybe maybe would have hindered me so I
bought in an ops manager at the time it
was working at a company Bristol core g2
she was very good output structure in
place etc and yeah so we did that and
then we started forging relationships
with good Rex Rex they were providing
trainees I'd always had the the thought
that trainees were were the right way to
go yeah you need new blood to grow a
business I personally feel right yeah
and you know I've coined that phrase
from from Dean Kelly actually you know
he he mentioned that to me once and
you know absolutely fantastic Guyanese
I'm Ryan I'm sure you know and I kind of
felt that like you know we're with
senior people sometimes it can be 50/50
and if they're that good why they
leaving
or why they're not setting up they're in
business you get a lot of journeymen in
recruitment you put a pop around and
trainees don't know any better and if
you teach people freeways the easy
medium and hard way they're going to go
for the easiest way so we started
bringing in trainees teaching them the
hardest way but but also what I think
the hardest right it's not just the
hardest cadets I mean it's the best way
right yeah so you know selling selling
candidates to jobs with no interviews
immediate starts trial starts yeah
clever stuff so that was year two and we
had an interview - what did you got -
and worship what how did that impact the
revenue and stuff that so I ran the
two-year mark or was you how many people
did you have working for you roughly yes
if there was a fair amount of attrition
because we bought people on and I think
a lot of the honesty yeah well you've
got to be honest right like you know
people lie numbers right see ya you
struggle with that why why do you think
that is so you have the opposite
I'm quite I'm think I'm quite soft
sometimes when it comes to people right
like I see the good in people
yeah and I feel as though I feel as
though I can make them good yeah but
what I was what I was perhaps wasn't
fully aware of visit sometimes at
trainee level sometimes people just want
a job you know and they say you say
anything and you can sit down you say
you know it's gonna be hard work it's
gonna be this you're not going to get
any success at twelve months etc
yeah but puttin myself back into trainee
mode yeah people just live in sometimes
hands mouth right at that point and they
just want a job so and I think the
implications are actually how hard it is
and would be turned a lot of people away
early on you know and you know as a
company we with foe
kriste on building contract builders
from scratch yeah and you taste a lot
hard work yeah yes no it's not gonna
happen overnight
yeah a lot of companies focused on perm
or sometimes people do desk you know we
don't we're doing things in the hard way
and and to be honest my opinion probably
the right way but we want a core team of
great people and the word great is
really interesting because I think these
days it's okay to be good right and it's
alright to come second but since when
did that become acceptable to not be
fantastic at something yeah it's like
you know do you want it do you want to
be okay at something would you want to
be fantastic at something yeah and
that's the main drive that I push
forward with the business when I'm
hiring people was that you know I want I
want them to be fantastic and sadly so
so go yeah so just going back to it the
second part second year so we had some
we had some really good people join and
we and we you know unfortunately hired
some people that didn't work out and I
got his impact numbers I think we had
steady growth but not massively
different and I think you know you you
know it doesn't take a rocket scientist
to work out the fact that you know good
biller sets up company does well has a
spike first year revenue goes super-high
you know this is why visa recruitment
companies and when you look at fast
track companies in the UK they're always
so so quick to grow because it's service
industry
there isn't a load of stocks at inner
yeah in a warehouse right you know you
can you can go up super quick and you
can have that year-on-year growth that
compounds quickly but for us and at that
time I became more managerial less
billing so therefore we didn't took we
yeah we didn't go super super we weren't
logarithmic in terms of our our Billings
in our turnover but what what I did do
was teach me about really refining
interview processes
knowing what to look for in people early
on and you know it could have been easy
to take the you know the experience
route and bring people in and
let them carry on what they were doing
but you know for for me as I mentioned
you know I really want fantastic people
to do fantastic things and got high
standards yeah high standards I suppose
because yeah we don't want you know we
don't as a business wanna be a lifestyle
business we want to be known as being
experts in what we do and paratus as an
a means prepared ready and skilled it
derives from the latin term right so you
can't go into business where the whole
mantra of the company is to be prepared
ready and skilled and to do it half
soaked right yeah so so you were so
you've just here for now so like so
financial year probably no incorporation
date was April 2016 to 20 so coming up
yeah okay so just just a quick one just
I guess so rounding off those two years
yeah what like advice advice for people
early on yeah in them building forming
having their own recruitment business
that you wish you'd received yeah okay
I think people spend too much time
looking left and right and forget to
look forward align yourself with people
that are proven that have walked it as
well as spoken it yeah there's a lot of
people out there that give advice that
haven't really done anything or maybe
even started a company from scratch and
been through all of the hardship that
that entails so I would say focus on
what you're good at and keep doing what
you could don't try to grow too quickly
and remember the fact that adding people
for the sake of having people is a bit
of a monk's game right you know focus on
growing and developing people slowly but
surely and maximizing everything that
you can do early on and do that
organically okay so is it fair to say
that the obviously you're getting to the
point now or have been on the journey of
as you said quite Ronnie said year one
it was just you smashing out yeah
obviously which which showed in the
revenue but and then over the last year
to year
you've obviously now been transitioning
into raw where it's your your job to
cultivate maximize the people you bring
into the business and yeah so I'm sure
that also involves helping the business
through your relationships and let's say
feeling the people around you right yeah
how basket and that's going to be
typical the love and commitment business
owners mm-hmm how do you because how
many people you act now so so was the
core team here we have eleven plus I
think we've got another person joining
and we have an outsource accounts team
plus also advisors who do compliance
commercial a mentor and learning and
development person and we would we might
be moving forward on a marketing person
soon as well that's okay so how have you
however you personally found that
transition because you learned on the
tools now I still attend meetings I
won't but you are you billing that no
well I've got a lot of house runners
which keep the company going because
they so that what that means a people
contractors at work view for a very long
time
either contractors that I placed at some
point during the journey of the company
or that have migrated from people that
have left the business and that go into
house so house my house one there's been
yeah that's what we call house but yeah
I think I'll still with ten meetings we
were at Amazon yesterday we've got a big
meeting tomorrow with a forty billion
pound a year turnover company he's still
involved in helping the people around
you yeah I really want to help the
people right you know I really want to
help my guys you know I say if you put a
hundred percent effort in are but two
hundred percent you know it sounds like
a cliche but I really mean it like we
have always on whatsapp groups you know
I live 15 minutes from the office if
people want to come in and talk about
something I'm there I can afford to do
that right now
I don't I don't have children and I'm a
single guy and I wouldn't want anyone
ever saying that they didn't get enough
support from us yeah because that's you
know that that would be that would be my
nightmare right
and nothing that I would want to I won't
want someone to feel so put a lot of
effort into that training development
you know where as I mentioned over lunch
well we're interview well we're not
interviewing where we potentially gonna
have a learning and development person
joining us a couple of days a month that
was very senior s free and yeah pouring
a lot of money into that and and two
people in judges really yeah offering
okay so how so how would what are some
of the key things that you think you've
done in this business and grind this
business that you've done that has
enabled your your people out there to
get to the standards or continue
performing at the standards you want
them to like how have you got how do you
think you've got the best out of your
people so I think there's a fine line
between being someone's mate and being
someone's boss yeah and I think that you
always have to walk that line carefully
especially yeah yeah and it's a mile
boss which similar-sized yeah as 12 of
us yeah it's like you do you would IVM
has a bit of IVM as a mental really but
I get I get that yeah especially in a
smaller business yeah I think I think
you have to yeah so so to answer that
question so I think I have to be seen as
a fairly aspirational figure of course
you know people want to look up to
someone leading by the front yeah yeah
exactly you know being there in the
trenches of your team and I think you
know for me sitting with people it's
jumping in on calls listening on calls
being able to help being always on and
and and and treading that thin line as
well between putting people in the
dependents even if they can swim right
but also being able to give them support
when they need it
because you don't want to be too
over-the-top because it becomes
arbitrary that the advice that you're
given is that people will wait for you
to come and sort yeah in this area yeah
so become a bit of a comfort blanket
absolutely yeah and that and that can be
the case and and you know that that that
is a difficult balance to meet yeah
bitchiness this size you are calm yeah
because you're so accessible yes
yeah and that's that's a really that's a
really good question really good phrase
right easy accessibility yeah so you
don't want to be seen as someone that
you can just answer straight away
because you need people to fat find so
you go back to the question you said
about when I started a company and what
what did I do and they said well as fact
finding right was being a recruiter I
was calling people I was making informed
decisions you know if you want to know
something you speak to find people and
you take the mean answer from what they
say right here you know and I think
that's the same for my guys is that you
know you want them to be able to do this
themselves and so they can come to me
and say hey Tom right like I've looked
at the training material I've gone
online I've YouTubed it of googled it
I've spoken to some colleagues what do
you think not Tom what do you mean do
like you're trying to get the answer out
of you straight away yeah and you and
you could argue that it's efficient
right and some of them were probably
probably you know quick enough to say
that but but equally it's not helping
them in the long term okay see you and
then how how's the Joe how's the journey
been for you personally lond like you
start this business on your own right
yeah I've spoken to a lot of people that
who started their business on their own
and and advice to people would be like
really considered in of another person
mm-hm
how has the journey been for you in
along an individual basis how have you
found that yeah it's it's been tough
I think at the start it's been tough
it's quite it's quite draining yeah I
think people that say it doesn't take
over your life a property line somewhat
I purposely started on my own because
I've seen many companies that have set
up with two founders who evolved many
fallen out yeah also for me starting a
business and owning 50% of it didn't
really make sense from where I was as an
individual in terms of the return on
who's coming here the Commission's yeah
so because I was on you know a high
commission structure in the past you
know it didn't really makes any sense I
got out
yeah but have you found navigating this
journey on your own cuz that's
definitely challenge right yeah it's a
challenge I think you have to be really
clued up about how you
your time with what with who and regimen
or and and fix skin right there's you
know there's those nights where you know
you can worry about stuff and and I
think ultimately it's it being able to
talk to someone
yeah who have you been out to talk soon
so yeah as I mentioned to you were part
of the peer group partly I'll just see
met some good friends from there being
able to talk to people about similar
issues know which is that how it helped
quite a lot to be honest of you and I'm
I'm pretty I'm pretty open about that
I'm an open type of guy right I think
within it within any pair ship group or
networking forum that you can go to and
I tried a few in the past
non non recruitment and recruitment
specific you know there's always again
skepticism over the agenda and why
people want to be there but it's as much
as you want to get out of it and it's
it's quite nice meeting people that are
in the same position as you right but
for me it was important to drive and get
a number two and because obviously we
you know we offer you know a fantastic
commission scheme and I mentioned if it
goes up to forty five percent on what
you built yeah it's like crazy and it's
really good but I'm happy to do that
right because for me I don't want to
give another reason for someone to go
elsewhere and I want people to be super
super happy so I've been able to develop
a number two through that okay who i can
work with who then I can release equity
to potentially down the line right
rather than it being a hard and fast you
own 50% of the business yeah so come in
coming back directly to answer your
question I think it might be easier at
the start but I think ultimately long
term you'd probably wished it's just you
and then how have you part obviously
you're in the big room which helps but
like just for people because I think a
lot and this has come up even from like
a billion perspective I'm speaking about
this with someone yesterday that you can
so easily just you could be sitting in
office right now yeah struggling with
something and just not just just not
making the decision to ask for help yeah
alright sounds really simple yeah but
just a lot of people won't so I guess
like how have you personally found that
has a bit
sign that when you've reached out to
people for help or whatever it may be
like how is that - what's your been your
typical experience of that for people
that may be a bit worried about reaching
out to people and get rejected and stuff
like that I think it boils down to the
fact that in early early training that
people are given or what have you the
most common thing that people say when
they pick up a phone and speak to a
client or a customers I wonder if you
can help and you know people naturally
want to help people
yeah you know you know people ask you
for directions in the street you don't
necessarily send them on a wild goose
chase right and let's do a bit weird
that's true so I think naturally people
who want to help they want to guide
people and they don't understand that
people who are in similar situations so
I think for me it's a case of aligning
yourself with the right people and still
people come to me you know I had a
question today from a mate of mine that
works at my old company asking me about
you know German legislation and what
have you and I was able to provide that
help and it's quite nice that people you
know come to you for that for that
advice but again it's aligning yourself
with the right people
take my advice on the right yeah and
experts that are in their field right
and you know it's not it's not hard to
work out you speak to you speak to a
right types of people and then you get a
gut feeling on who you can go with who's
right who's saying the same things and
just having a good black book of
contacts yeah so you've obviously from
what I understand about your business
you've obviously you operate a lot in
there EU yeah so because how much
business dude in the UK so traditionally
it was small ways like 10% yeah and then
we want a pretty major account with Sky
Television and started doing quite a lot
more work with them people people live
obviously there but the other obviously
followed the political environment now
yeah all that like really very
experienced in working and these types
of markets yeah any learnings there that
if someone's looking to break into these
markets that yeah you can share yeah I
think it's I think it's cultural I think
you need to understand your market place
yeah
from a brexit perspective as soon as a
referendum happened I applied for my
Irish passport yeah I need to do that
yeah get on it I need to do that need to
do it quick
it might say no no right really yeah why
I don't know maybe the over the Irish
passports actually came out yeah off the
back of that yeah so I think I think you
need to to try and incorporate yourself
income in country where possible yeah
so our terms are indicative and
reflective of where we are doing
business okay so we don't do business in
the Netherlands and the UK terms we do
it under the courts of of the
Netherlands and under instead of under
the courts of the UK and you know I
would say 90% of the business in the UK
that doing work in the EU are doing it
under the UK business which is in theory
the wrong thing to do but if you ever
have any challenging situations and what
have you it can be difficult to pursue
debt make those stand like yeah and that
may something yeah so um so set yourself
up to be future proof and speak to the
right people and where possible get an
Irish passport and then your any uses
and so what I love are just a couple of
questions are may actually what actually
one thing actually how this is one of
the things are write down because it's
definitely I've something that business
owners would deftly think about like how
much like of a salwar it head down here
is like how much of it on the hip wait
house like this so how much will your
profits take a hit or how much should I
prepare for my profits take a hit
should I plan for when hiring like when
trying to grow my business have you got
any thoughts on that cool so you try
some a SAN life it so if you a farm
listening right now and I'm not right
over the next over the next two years on
a hot on aim to hire this amount of
people right yeah how like in terms of
profit wise or revenue wise how much
should I prepare to take a hit on that
do you I mean from your experience so I
think I think it depends on the nature
of the business course I think if you're
permanent you need to be putting money
away for a rainy day
yeah and I think people talk about three
six months worth of
cash in the bank three to six months oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean if you look
at some big perm businesses you look at
the direct use feature to directors they
always say there's six months and going
bankrupt right get that perm only it's
you only as good as your last month here
and you can replicate that but a number
of employees that you have I think if
it's contract it's all about the
Headroom that you have with the facility
at the bank ultimately I think you know
to answer your question logically is
don't run before you can walk
okay you know take on people make sure
they're billing get them up to you know
if it's contract get them up to a knife
grand a week yeah all right so you've
got some hiring sort of metrics yeah
that went to higher and higher in points
so if you've got a good finance person
we've got a great finance person you
have a cash flow and a forecast and you
can inject hiring points into that nice
so you can actually work out exactly
when you need to hire the hiring through
this yet hiring triggers that was
absolutely in fact I think that's
actually what they call is it yes you
work that's of work so on a contract
playing dumb you already know this
you already know they share that and
that's really valuable so on the
obviously again obviously relevant T's
person's business but from your
experience what's been a typical good
hiring trigger for you so I think it's
when you know that someone is gonna be
standalone so they understand the value
the business and that's quite an
interesting metric oh so you talk about
that because it's actually there's a
book called gung-ho right and a lot of
people have read Champa Fresno comment I
did it yeah that's that's because his
Ned probably told him to read it because
yeah Garrett Gary said that and it's
actually a really good book to be honest
and Jamie's a nice guy yeah in that book
yes in that but I think they say
something like enthusiasm is it is is
equal to the mission multiplied by cash
and congratulations oh wow okay it's an
interesting than question yeah so what
that essentially means is you know when
to go again when that person musi astok
you know for want of a better phrase if
you cut them they would bleed the
company right and I think once you've
got to that point and you know that
they're billing for hire and trigger
that's a hiring trigger and you could
probably do it a little bit earlier
right I mean you don't have to
necessarily you've got a good eye yeah
you should have a good good I think you
know and I think in a smaller business
use of knowing and I think perhaps you
know you're you're hiring triggers
should come from your team leads in the
future I would say once they can predict
when people are going to start doing
well
in order to go again because you want to
go again you want to go done you said
getting your again your recruit ought to
like two-and-a-half koe yeah he's a good
boss right yeah
so des costs can range from you know
phreak phreak a up to i've seen des cost
above ten grand a fifteen grand even
right yeah which is a lot of money yeah
that's everything from the lights again
desk desk being covered is profit and on
a growth trajectory you know they need
to be on the grave of trajectory not a
downward yeah yeah yeah and I think when
you when you get in there early and you
can just keep and you keep doubling down
on the hiring from that and looking
what's good driving internal referrals
and things like that you know the scent
advising your people to do that okay a
couple of questions and resilience go
for it first one yeah what does
resilience and recruitment mean to you
from a consultant perspective it's it's
knowing that you're gonna get knowed a
lot and you know people talk about six
knows to get a yes right you have to be
fit skinned you have to know that
someone came before you and someone will
come after you so how do you
differentiate yourself and how do you
stay resilient and tough to people not
wanting to talk to you I mean that's
tough for people you know it's tough to
ring someone and for people was toned to
be off and and abrasive abrupt and want
to get you off the phone that's then
that's the mark of resilience as a
consultant from a business owner
perspective
it's it's taken the highs and the lows
seeing the long term vision of what
you're trying to do what you're trying
to create knowing that you know there's
going to be dark days and there's going
to be bright nights or whatever right
how do you have way around it yeah and
yeah and I think it being resilient and
being tough and you know nothing nothing
good happens overnight really so answer
your question yeah how how has the
importance or need for resilience
changed as the industry has evolved so
the industry is evolved yeah it's
certainly evolved so as I mentioned and
it's probably a nice link that
recruitment in its traditional sense is
dying if not dead yeah in fact we try
and remove recruitment from all our
literature it's all about solutions
Augmented solutions embedding your
talent on-site outsourcing house
approaches talent acquisition as a
service loads of different ways in which
you can wrap things up in bundles and
products ization yeah and there's some
people doing some super smart things
around it right and the resilience side
of that is that the fact that you need
to you know you need to be up to speed
with the changes and you need to be
resilient to know that the old methods
may be changing and may be dying and of
course saturation right it's there's big
I mean I don't know the official stats
but it's something about 41,000 it's a
lot yeah
it's a lot I quite like that mmm a lot
of people don't like it a lot of people
think Oh crikey but I think you know
there's a lot of bad companies out there
yeah and you need you need bad companies
mm to make good companies look good okay
what can people do themselves to instill
more resilience in themselves or their
teams so to instill resilience I think
goes back down to basics yeah so in a
team or a team lead or a business owner
depending on the size of the business so
for me yeah I would
go back down to why someone joined yeah
and go back through the job spec and go
back through actually the attributes
that we were looking for the power of
communication a power of influence and
saying are you showing these traits I
used are you still doing these things
and and to reinforce the fact that you
know people agreed to do this and that
they knew it was gonna be tough and to
go back to basics web training with what
they're doing and to instill the fact
that you know it's your show is called a
recruitment rollercoaster right yeah you
know and I think that people need to be
aware that it is a rollercoaster yeah
but but get back get back to basics to
make sense what about what about from
your perspective colvin that in people
isn't the same sort of I thinking about
yeah I think I think it's about back to
basics the pingers about you know being
pragmatic with your situation know
everything will be alright in the end
and if it isn't it isn't the end keep
focusing on you know where you've been
successful in the past and analysis of
that right a lot of people analyze bad
situations but it never analyzed good
situations
so you just look at the bad stuff that's
gone yeah I mean people draw a meeting
when things go wrong right draw meeting
when things go right yeah so the
resicert of resilience element is about
really plugging away and saying that
yeah it is gonna get bumpy yeah there's
going to be turbulence on the way right
but you can go through it and as long as
you equip yourself with the basic basic
like that then you'll get through okay
before I actually the last question sure
what what you was Tom why excited about
what's going on in 2020 and beyond me
were you excited about personal work
perspective either either right so I
think for me right 2020 is a big years
like 2020 vision and all these new
decade all that jazz right I think for
me it's about really cement in the
business about where I want to go yeah
we've got some super exciting projects
happening big meetings I've got
later on this month about run at a
solution for literally hundreds of
Engineers how we're gonna gonna do that
how we're gonna handle some growth I
think you know recruitment is evolving
you know into into 4.0 right and in the
very market that we recruit within and I
think it's going to be an interesting
time and I think it's booming right now
there going to be a downturn at some
point and a lot of people become rich in
downturns right and I think you have to
be clever so I'm quite looking forward
to that mmm I'm quite looking forward to
being a survival of the fittest yeah
going back to basics maybe I get to pick
up the phone again I don't know yeah and
I guess for myself personally I think um
I think it's better being able to find a
better balance this year as well right
and having a having a good team around
you knowing that the bulk of the
Billings and the bulk of what keeps the
company going isn't necessarily derived
from what I had done yeah and that's
that's a lovely feeling and seeing
people hit milestones and where they
want to be you know one of our guides
had just bought you know big Range Rover
right and it's and it's wicked to see
you're like yeah we weren't lying to you
like you know you can actually do this
you know go right back to what got me
into the groove and someone talked about
hundred twenty thousand years it's like
they actually see some of my team buy
expensive cars and nice things or stuff
that they own yeah so lots more of that
in 2020 basically yeah senior guys and
gals do well yeah seeing them do well
I've seen how the industry of olds right
and seen what happens and being being
prepared for it at every step so last
question
yeah ask everyone on the show so if you
could communicate to every single
recruit out there business owner mm-hm
they take on Tom's advice they'd listen
and implement it tomorrow it could be a
phrase sentence a word what you telling
the people so anyone involved in our
recruiters couldn't business owners
whatever comes to mind what would you
say to these people I'd say remember why
you got into this
you know remember why you got into the
industry yeah do you know what I could
elaborate more on it but I think that's
enough yeah that is enough
remember why I got into the industry
yeah it's always been a pleasure mate
thank you so much all right